we have a fun day of baseball in store
for you today a double header against
the oakland athletics
marco gonzalez who has had an incredible
year thus far
for the seattle mariners he'll be making
his ninth start of the season ninth
career start versus the oakland
athletics
and simeon leads out for the iss against
marco gonzalez what you want to watch
for
is the superb command of marco gonzalez
a big breaking ball there you go there's
his fifth walk of the year
and that's the way our ball game begins
and tommy listella is coming up brown
ball in the left for a base hit and the
asf first and second and nobody out
here's right fielder stephen piscotti
swinging a fly ball down the left field
line on the run mar malayos reaches out
and he makes the catch tagging at second
heading for third simeon
the throw to seeger offline kyle has to
go to his right
so now the a's have runners at first and
third with one out
brings up left fielder mark cannon swing
at a miss for strike three
so strikeout number one for marco
gonzalez
that's exactly what he needed and
there's two outs for the a's here in the
top of the first inning that'll bring up
first base with matt olsen
swing and a foul tip into the glove but
terence hangs down to it for strike
three and marco gonzalez
gets himself out of a jam lefty jesus
lizardo
for the oakland a's making his tenth
appearance eighth start of the season
dylan moore leads it off against jesus
lozado
more swings and misses blown away by a
fastball
96. here's second baseman ty france
and that is on the inside corner of
fastball ring him up and
france said wait a minute i thought that
pitch was up so
back-to-back strikeouts for jesus
lazardo two outs for the mariners here
in the bottom of the first
swung on who missed off speed away and
down goes lewis and he sues lizardo
what a start he strikes out the side in
a one two three bottom of the first now
the a's will have runners on at first
and third with two outs and now marco
has to take a look at marcus simeon
and he swings at the first pitch lines
it into left field for a base hit
chris davis will score the ball gets
past marmaleo's
so everybody's gonna move up an extra
base and the a's have a
nothing lead so now the a's have runners
on it's second
and third with two outs for tommy
lestella swinging a ground ball a little
wider first but right there evan white
he's got it goes to the back for the out
on the stella and that will retire the
side the a's
get the one run with two outs for the
mariners they have their first hit
that'll bring up philip irvin swung on a
fly ball
right center field shallow long run for
laureano goes into a dive
and he makes a great play fabulous play
by lauriano ramon
racing into short right center full out
extension
and takes it right off the grass
mariners in business here with runners
at first
and second and one away so here's ty
france swings and
pops it up first base side for olson
straddles the line makes the catch for
the second out
now two outs for kyle lewis the swing
gotta miss fastball upstairs some high
octane
sixth strikeout for lizardo as he dances
out of trouble here in the third sean
murphy the catcher gonna lead things off
for oakland
that one is hit very high very deep down
the left field line
and that baby
is gone launch angle check
all the board next stop pound town
two nothing age teams have runners at
the corners with one out now for marcus
simeon hayes would love a crooked number
here
pulled deep to left a hammer shot off
the bat of marcus simeon
and out it goes into the second deck
over the
edgar's assign bombs away for simeon
a three-run blow it's five-nothing
oakland police torrens the catcher who
had a base hit in the second one of just
two hits
off lizardo swung on lifted to right
field and deep biscotti back racing
towards the wall
makes a leap at the wall it's off his
glove and then off the wall and it got
over the wall
terence has a home run off of the glove
of biscotti
and it's a long ball the first for
terence in the mariners uniform how
about that the mariners are on the board
it's now five to one
rizardo has fans seven in the game he's
been excellent he's allowed three hits
as jose marmaleos starts the fifth for
seattle
swung on and stroke to center field this
one is smashed deep racing back loriano
looking up and this one is gone
solo home run jose marmaleos
and the mariners inch closer it's now
five to two oaklanders making some noise
trying to
sneak back into the ball game a couple
of well struck balls in the setting
against lizardo
now to bring kyle lewis to the plate
lewis is k twice he's over his last
13. swung on and destroyed the center
field this one is back
it is way back it is gone no
doubt about it and the mariners just
like that
have cut the lead to one boy he's pumped
too as well as should be hit the
daylights out of that ball
so two down one aboard and that'll bring
up designated hitter tim lopes
swinging a fly ball into the gap in
right center field on the run l'oreal
this is gonna get down
for extra bases bourbon scores without a
throw
in its second tim lopes with his third
double
we are even it's the mariners five
and the athletics five holy smokes and
the mariners have the bases loaded here
in the bottom of the sixth inning
and here comes kyle lewis three nothing
pitch
up and in ball four a bases loaded walk
to lewis that will force in
tim lopes from third with a goal head
run
and there's two down for the a's here on
the top of the seventh and final inning
he's swinging the ground ball the white
at first he's got it
steps on the bag and the ball game is
over the mariners come back from a
five-nothing deficit
to beat the oakland a's this afternoon
six to five